yo what's up i'm rich i'm eric i'm
christopher i'm joe i'm sabile and we
are
cnco and today we're going to be going
over our shoes and determining who has
the best kicks
flashes i think these are my flashiest
shoes
these are jordan's 11s i got them in l.a
yeah they were like 2k something like
that i think they robbed me to be honest
um i think we had like an award in
puerto rico and i bought it before that
and i was gonna wear it there so yeah it
shines in the sun right now you can't
see it on here
but right now like you can see it on the
sun and stuff like that so it's super
cool
[Music]
this is the louis vuitton trainer i just
was shopping and i sit and i was like
wait that's cool and i just buy them
yeah i usually use with white outfits
and i like them
[Music]
this rock siemens costs kind of like 600
it was a gift
from my video this part is like black
the black part
and this part is metallic i love it
because
like every time i use it everybody like
look at them
rarest well these shoes are called the
union air jordan one
so i really like this shoe because it
has like different colors you know you
can kind of wear it with anything street
wear
i like the shoelaces it goes like from
black to tan
and then it has like this little stitch
um detail that's like blue
i left this here because i like it i've
walked around the street sometimes and
people are like why no way you have
those
and i was like what because i was
confused because at first they were like
selling normally but now
i know they're over 1k
i don't know i think it's a really cool
shoe it's pretty unique yo yo yo me
i have the reddish shoes
these are the valentino undercover
silver climber
remember i got them from workshop last
time i wore this
was when we were traveling to la i think
because they're comfortable too this
700 800
i like that detail on the back that's
really nice it's like it's cool with
the v these are converse
asap nasa edition i haven't worn them
yet
because i got it right before everything
started like the whole corona thing
these are fresh because you know the
corduroys as well and it has like fire
on the side
it has like these colors on the side so
it looks crazy
um it also shines when like the the sun
hits i like the black
you know the black souls it's cool man
it's a little vibe as soon as
all this is over man i think i'm gonna
put him on and i'm just gonna like
jump outside so this shoe
costs like about twelve hundred dollars
i believe
this one is uh versace i wore them
actually for the video of vegeto and
these were so comfortable because i had
like a like a sprained ankle
so these kind of like help me you know
stay up and kind of keep a balance
it has like a wide sole so it was cool
to just like lean on it you know so i
like this this uh
shoe because this is red and it has um
it's kind of like first so it feels it
feels nice you know
um and i like the plastic on the side it
kind of gives it like a vibe
i like this the design on the back the
versace design so it's cool
underrated so these are alexander
mcqueen's
oversized runner my underrated shoes i
think they're fired
but i don't i don't think that people
kind of like them because they look like
marshmallows to be honest on you on your
feet they look like marshmallows
because they're really like kind of big
and they have this big platform um but
they're really comfortable and
i use this for a show
uh to travel a lot i got them from a
wardrobe too
we had to perform and i got this
they actually look fresh bro yeah they
fire i like oh yeah
they look like marshmallows they look
like
i think these are underrated these are
converse
these are my favorite shoes ever man
because i feel like they're so
comfortable i wore these to dance ones
uh for an award it was super comfortable
i never danced on this before i like my
converse dirty by the way
i don't like to clean my converse
they are valentino i think it's
underrated now everybody like this
style i love it and i wear it for like
almost everything you can tell it's like
a little dirty stuff
the material is pretty cool because this
part of here
it's like a sock and it's so comfortable
inside
like you think you're in a cloud so they
kind of sell this like separately too
and you can change the colors yeah last
time i were
i think it was when we used to like fly
i think it was from my flight from a
lake
really really important to be
comfortable on the plane
i'm gonna start with the sexiest one of
course
look how they come in look they come in
sexy oh look at
that look at that it was
good boom look at this babies right here
i think though they look like like
astronaut
shoes i don't know what brand are these
to be honest
they're bb and i i don't use them that
much because they're so like
they're so sexy that just if i wear them
it's like
too too sexy going around nah it's too
much
and and
if these two they're louboutins and i
think they're pretty sexy
and this i have a really cool story
because these are the ones that the guys
gave it to me as my gift and my birthday
those those
right now they're kind of dirty but
in their moments but they're still sexy
i love them because
they make me very tall and i don't know
the details that they have like
yellow here um red
blue this is a compliment but every time
i see somebody wearing these shoes it
gives me like
transformers vibes you know yeah i love
them it's one of my favorite shoes
[Music]
i do have a contender they're they're
sexy because they're they're just
all black you know what i'm saying we
have to see them yo these are pretty
freaking
these are the brothers of richards the
one that that he had for the
oh it's the same oh okay yeah the same
mother
but you know black is always the color
oh hold on hold on these are the sexiest
these are the one that will win the
battle of all time
yeah damn sparkly though they look sexy
these are about me i've been having
these for a little bit
uh and i feel like they're my favorite
dress-up shoes of all time
i wore these actually in puerto rico for
after party or something like that
i could wear these anytime they're one
of my favorite shoes that i have
[Music]
these are ugly but these are still cool
so i might just use these again
this is what they think yeah
[Laughter]
these ones are um wraps
siemens but you can put any color socks
exactly
exactly i think people think that these
shoes are ugly
but i think they are super cool because
like richard said you can wear um
different socks and give
different vibes they are comfortable to
be honest
i think mine is ugly to the eye of other
people but i think they're really sick
for me these are the
martine rose nikes yeah i feel like
people wouldn't like them because
because of this they might think they're
like stepped on for a while or something
and it kind of got like messed up but i
like them personally
the color is insane yeah the color is
crazy uh
the the pink panther pink
last time i wore these was about a year
ago
for the billboards i always thought they
were sick since from the beginning i was
like well they're so different and the
color is super cool
kind of like like big shoes see inside
it's like if it's a normal shoe it's
just the
i think this is just like filled in you
know like if it's just a bump and it's
filled in with i don't know what with
rubber
but it's pretty comfortable and it gives
you like an inch
some people that are not as open to like
changing up their styles they might
think it's ugly
but some some people see them in
different perspectives yeah
we all have different perspectives i
think all right so that was all from us
uh cnc we had so much fun doing this we
hope you guys enjoyed it
um please stay home take care of
yourselves and don't forget to listen to
honeyboo
hello cnco thank you guys